NARRATOR: The
following content is
provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome to
another exciting day
of Engineering
Innovation and Design.
We'll read some
interesting things today
so the pace might be
a little bit faster.
Here we go.
Pop quiz.
I've given you a
piece of paper there.
If you don't have that paper
you can use your own paper.
This is the pop quiz.
It's going to be given orally.
Are you ready?
I want you to tell
me what questions I
would ask you on
a pop quiz today.
That is your pop quiz.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Could you
repeat that question?
PROFESSOR: I'd be happy to.
It sounds a bit circular, right?
I want you to tell
me what you think
I would ask you on
a pop quiz today
if I were giving you
a quiz on the material
that we've had so far.
AUDIENCE: What are the 10
steps in the design process.
PROFESSOR: You should
just write this down.
But I'm sure everyone would
appreciate your answer
because it's a good one.
So write that down.
You might have two
or three answers.
I'll give you about 34
seconds to fill that out.
And time.
Take your papers.
Pass them over to this side of
the room all the way that side.
And pass them to the
top down once you've
collected all those papers.
Now-- and let's do it
quietly-- here's the question.
What questions would I ask you?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Your name.
That's a great one.
Keep going.
AUDIENCE: Do we write our names?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
You should write your name
on your paper, of course.
Yes.
That's so I know who wrote this.
But that would be a good
question to ask on a pop quiz--
your name.
AUDIENCE: What is innovation.
PROFESSOR: What is innovation.
That's great.
What else?
AUDIENCE: A few characteristics
of good and bad design?
PROFESSOR: A few
characteristics of?
Of good and bad design.
Sure.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I believe
I've already stated--
PROFESSOR: You did.
And it was a great one.
Could you restate it?
AUDIENCE: What are the 10
steps of the design process.
PROFESSOR: The 10
step design process.
That's a wonderful one.
Because that may even occur
on a subsequent pop quiz.
AUDIENCE: What makes a
good design critique.
PROFESSOR: What makes
a good design critique.
Excellent.
AUDIENCE: What's the most
important question to ask.
PROFESSOR: What's the
most important question
to ask particularly when
you're given a problem.
Absolutely.
That's a great one.
Any other ones?
You did a great job.
You all get A's.
So that's the beginning.
So look for these
questions that may
appear on subsequent
pop quizzes.
Let's start in here.
I want to know if anybody here
knows who these two people are.
Anybody know who this
person is on the right?
Tell me.
Who is it?
AUDIENCE: John Ive.
PROFESSOR: Johnny Ive.
Absolutely.
And what does Johnny Ive do?
AUDIENCE: He's the
Chief Designer at Apple.
PROFESSOR: Yup.
Chief Designer at Apple
for hardware products.
AUDIENCE: Industrial Designer.
PROFESSOR: Industrial Designer.
Exactly.
And on the left-- this guy
here in the black and white
picture-- who's he?
Hah.
Not as famous as
Johnny Ive, I guess.
Oh, maybe he is.
Hold on.
AUDIENCE: Is it Dieter Rams?
PROFESSOR: It is Dieter Rams.
Absolutely.
Dieter Rams and Johnny Ive--
two very important people.
Let's show you a
little bit about them.
Dieter Rams was born
in 1932 in Germany.
And he's closely
associated with something
called the functionalist
school of industrial design.
He made these things.
Johnny Ive was born
a lot later in 1967.
And you're all
familiar with his work
from having experienced it
firsthand or seen it firsthand.
These are Dieter Rams' work.
These are Johnny Ive's work.
Let's do that again.
This is what Dieter Rams made.
And, interestingly enough,
Johnny Ives made these.
Do you notice any parallels?
Let's take a look some more.
Johnny Ive on the right.
Dieter Rams on the left.
And would you believe Johnny
on the right and Dieter Rams
on the left?
Again, Johnny Ive on the
right with a speaker that
has an iPod on top of it
and a speaker over here
that has a phonograph on it.
An iMac.
A speaker.
Johnny Ive.
Dieter Rams.
Johnny Ive on the right.
It's like a television.
Doesn't it look
like a television?
And here it's a television.
So this interesting.
That's a speaker I guess.
What is this product?
AUDIENCE: An iPod.
PROFESSOR: It is an iPod.
And what is this product?
AUDIENCE: A radio.
PROFESSOR: It's a radio.
It's a radio.
So here's the question.
They didn't talk about
this for a very long time--
Johnny Ive and Dieter Rams.
So we're going to put
ourselves back up a few months
or a few years ago when no
one knew what's going on here
or how they felt
about each other.
What do you think about this?
What do you think about
this when you see this?
AUDIENCE: Legally different.
PROFESSOR: Legally different?
Legally.
What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: It wouldn't be
copyright infringement.
PROFESSOR: It's not
Yeah, totally different.
These look totally
different from each other.
I know there's no
way you could see
any similarity in this
corpus of work at all.
Don't tell the Apple lawyers
who are suing Samsung--
or who sued Samsung
successfully.
What else?
What else do you think
of when you see this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Good
design is repeated.
PROFESSOR: Good
What do you mean by repeated?
AUDIENCE: Used again.
PROFESSOR: That's pretty clever.
Used again.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: It's very--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: So she's
saying that good design,
you just use the same
thing over again.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Not quite?
Am I shading it?
OK.
Let's see what-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: No, that's all.
PROFESSOR: OK, fine.
If you think of
something, let me know.
AUDIENCE: As long
as you don't have
to redesign the
wheel, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So adapting
designs for what you need, OK.
What else?
AUDIENCE: While the designs
are very similar and shared
between them, the products
themselves are very different.
PROFESSOR: Ah.
He says the designs are similar
but the products are different.
Tell me.
I see a music player on
the left and a music player
on the right.
This one fits in your pocket.
This one has a circular
thing that spins
and this is a circular
thing that spins.
This allows you to select stuff.
That circle and this circle
allows you to select stuff.
Tell me are they different?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: A little different.
Sure.
Because it's a screen
over here on the right.
And a hard drive, yes.
Actually it's kind of funny.
Right now, interestingly, if you
buy an iPod Touch or something,
you don't have to have
music on your iPod.
It streams it wirelessly over
the air much like a radio.
Fascinatingly similar.
Everything old is new again.
So you say they're different,
but they're kind of similar.
What else?
How do you think
they feel about this?
that Dieter Rams felt
when he saw these
things coming out?
AUDIENCE: Happy?
PROFESSOR: Happy.
Why happy?
AUDIENCE: He insprired a whole
new generation of design.
PROFESSOR: There we go.
So he says, I'm so glad you're
copying all my hardware.
I feel like I've really,
really contributed
a lot more to society
because of this.
That's one interpretation.
What if someone was sitting
next to you during a test
and took that philosophy?
Would you feel happy about the
fact that they were inspiring
a whole new set of A's?
I don't know.
At what point have you ever
made something or thought, hey,
you're copying our stuff?
AUDIENCE: You want to look at
whoever wrote the textbook.
You're reading the textbook
and putting down the knowledge.
You're stealing from them.
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
I don't know.
This is interesting.
So we have these things that
definitely seem very similar.
But what's interesting
is that they both believe
in the same
fundamental approaches
to how to design great stuff.
And they might have come
to similar conclusions
either knowingly, because
of this form factor,
maybe somewhat unknowingly
and they realized,
boy this looks a
little bit like this,
what can we learn from that.
What is step number two?
AUDIENCE: The information phase.
PROFESSOR: The
information phase, yes.
The information phase.
So how can we leverage
what's out in the world
already to inform our design?
And they might have looked at--
I don't know-- 50 or 100 or 200
different ideas and came on
this one or a group of them
that looked like this.
And he said, it reminds
me of this other thing
that I saw a long time
ago, when I was a kid.
And I loved the way it worked.
So yes.
I think you're
right about this--
that great design has
a lot of similarities.
And you'll see this
happening throughout history.
Things change very
little in history.
There are few changes that
occur-- fundamental changes.
Take a look at kitchens.
Kitchens in the past-- I
don't know, let's say 60,
70 years-- have only
had really two changes
that are substantive.
One of them is that there
are now-- almost always when
the new kitchens are
designed-- open to another room
or to an area where
people can entertain.
People use the kitchen
differently now
as a way of connecting
with people.
Before, you'd shut
off the kitchen.
You close the door.
And you bring out the food.
And you say, look at this
beautiful food and not the mess
in the kitchen.
That changed.
And microwave ovens changed.
Who here has a microwave oven?
Wow.
And who here has
a microwave oven
and doesn't have
their own kitchen?
So some of you don't
even have a kitchen
and you've got a microwave oven.
Pretty amazing.
That's a big change.
Otherwise, we've
got refrigeration.
We've got a stove.
About the same height as
all the stoves before it.
We've got ovens.
If you're rich, you
might have two ovens.
Maybe you have a
garbage disposal now,
but there's not a
whole bunch of changes.
Things change very slowly.
So we'll see this in design.
And what's interesting is
that Dieter Rams came up
with these 10 principles
of good design.
So let's discuss them.
I want you to tell me, for
each of these principles,
what you think they mean and
if you think they're any good.
Good design is innovative.
What does that mean that
good design is innovative?
How about this.
Who thinks good design is
not innovative-- does not
have to be innovative?
Give me some example.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sure.
To prove that good design does
not have to be innovative.
AUDIENCE: The one
you just showed us?
PROFESSOR: So you're
saying that this was not
an innovation over this?
AUDIENCE: Well, parts of it.
PROFESSOR: Part of it.
What part?
AUDIENCE: The way it looks.
PROFESSOR: Is innovative?
Or not innovate?
AUDIENCE: Not if you're
comparing it to the other one.
PROFESSOR: How come?
This is made of plastic.
This has different
kinds of plastic.
It's got a screen on it.
It's got four buttons
on the outside.
It's got headphones that
are attached to it instead
of using a speaker.
You think it's too similar?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm saying
that it's as innovative.
I think it doesn't have
to be extremely innovative
because I'm saying
they look very similar.
There are innovations
but they're not drastic.
PROFESSOR: Would you
say an iPod is not
a drastic innovation
over a radio?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I'm
saying it is, but I'm
saying the physical
appearance of it.
PROFESSOR: The
physical appearance
may not be innovative.
Other examples?
I'm going to bring this
other slide back up.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Some of
the things that we've
been using since forever,
like a bowl or something--
it's really basic but I
think it's good design.
PROFESSOR: A bowl
is a good design.
But if someone made a new bowl--
AUDIENCE: It could
be a good design
and innovate but I don't
think it's required.
PROFESSOR: You
don't it's required?
So a new bowl doesn't have to be
innovative to be well designed
or to be a good design.
That's interesting.
AUDIENCE: To go back
to the last example,
innovation also
depends on the context
when you're looking
at the design.
PROFESSOR: What do
you mean the context
in looking at the design?
What do you mean it
depends on the context?
AUDIENCE: So right now,
before I saw Dieter Rams,
I was of the opposite
position of Johnny Ives.
But now I that I see a
different context, maybe I see
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
That's interesting.
Context.
What do you mean context, now?
What's your context?
AUDIENCE: It's what I know
about those kinds of designs.
PROFESSOR: It's what you know.
Context about what you know.
Could it be something
else as well?
AUDIENCE: Context
of similar designs
and their past designs
related to that.
PROFESSOR: A broader context.
What else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I would have to argue
that this design is innovate
because if a design is very
good, then there is no reason
you want to improve it.
PROFESSOR: If a design is
very good if there's no?
AUDIENCE: There's no
reason to improve it.
PROFESSOR: No reason
to improve it.
AUDIENCE: If you come
up with something that's
good than from
what is was before
and it's selling
well then there's
clearly some improvement.
PROFESSOR: She said if
you have a new product
and it's selling
well then there's
clearly some improvement.
What if it's not
selling so well?
Could it be innovative?
AUDIENCE: It could
also be innovative
because I think the innovation
is defined-- well, not defined,
but it about when you decide
that needs to be redesigned.
PROFESSOR: Innovation
comes about when
you decide it needs
to be redesigned.
Interesting.
Other ideas?
I think context is
very interesting here
and a little unusual.
Context-- we look at the
world in a certain way.
By a show of hands
here, who thinks
that their hairstyle
looks ridiculous?
There are no hands that went up.
Who here thinks that people
whose-- they see pictures
of people from the '80s
have ridiculous hairstyles?
Yeah, a lot more
hands go up now.
How about the '70s?
So you don't think that in 20
years you're going to look back
at pictures of yourself and go,
I cannot believe my hair looked
like that?
Context, right?
Context of our society.
Angel goes, no way,
his hair looks great.
That's awesome.
I'm always keeping this thing.
And he may.
He may keep that.
Some things are a little
more timeless than others.
Do you know something
interesting about art forgery?
Anyone know a lot
about art forgery?
So if there's a piece of
art from the-- let's say,
early 1800s-- and let's
suppose it's now 1920.
And I have hired Jacob
to forge a piece of art--
he's a great art forger.
Well, if he's great, at the time
when they had these forgeries,
you wouldn't be able to
tell that it was a forgery.
But 30, 40, 50 years later, you
say, oh, that's the forgery.
I can tell.
Because unconsciously, Jacob
sees the world around him
and he begins to put in
elements of contemporary design
into that piece.
And 50 years later, the
context has changed,
and you can see it.
You can see the stuff in there.
You can see those
differences and everything
he's done to balance out
all the small differences.
And it looks like a forgery.
It's pretty amazing.
So maybe this is true.
Maybe it's not true.
How about this one?
Good design makes
a product useful.
Is that true?
Who thinks it's not true?
Who thinks it is true?
What does it mean?
What does it mean to be useful?
I want to know what
it means to be useful.
AUDIENCE: Satifies a need.
PROFESSOR: Satisfies a need.
Tell me more about that.
What's a need?
Do I need to listen to all
my music wherever I am?
I kind of need to.
I get bored easily.
Satisfies a need
or maybe something
less serious than a need.
AUDIENCE: If it adds value.
PROFESSOR: Adds value.
What does it mean to add value?
What is value?
Any ideas?
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: Performs an
action efficiently.
PROFESSOR: Performs
an action efficiently.
Does art perform an
action efficiently?
AUDIENCE: It depends on
how if art is useful.
PROFESSOR: Well, yes.
Is art useful?
I don't know.
Is art design?
Oh, different topic.
Reserved for a different day.
What else?
AUDIENCE: It does what
it was designed to do.
PROFESSOR: Designed to do.
It does what it
was designed to do.
So good design makes
a product useful
because it's doing what
it's supposed to do.
It has fulfilled its
intended purpose.
AUDIENCE: I think I'd like
to argue that because I think
that you could have a useful
product that has a purpose that
wasn't intended by
the manufacturer.
PROFESSOR: A useful
product whose purpose
was not intended by
the manufacturer.
Let's consider this.
This is risky.
This is a brand new Apple
Macintosh Retina Display
MacBook Pro which I'm going
to use as a door stop.
Oh, yeah.
Not int--
[LAUGHTER]
Can we get a close
up on that one?
Can we see this over here?
I don't know if you
can see it down here.
This is my pride and joy here
being used as a door stop.
Not intended by
the manufacturer.
Pretty useful if we need
to prop open the door
I suppose I could prop it open.
Oh god, that scraping
sound sounds terrible.
Anything for you guys.
Anything.
So look how nice it
props the door open
if we didn't have
something else.
Again, not intended
by the manufacturer
who had to work on the
tolerances of this device.
So that's interesting.
What if it didn't performance
its intended action
and I found a new use for it?
Is it still useful?
I could have an Acer or
something that I would think--
or maybe a five-year-old
Acer that's very, very slow
and doesn't work very well and
I need to get rid of it anyway.
And it's broke.
It's falling apart.
And the screen-- every time I
move it the screen falls off.
And I can take it and make
it a very useful doorstep.
Not its intended purpose at all.
AUDIENCE: I still don't think
that it's a good design just
because it has a use, though,
because you used it as a door
stop but I still don't think
that is one of the best
choices for a door stop.
PROFESSOR: You don't think
it's the best choice for a door
stop?
I think it's a
beautiful door stop.
Maybe the MacBook Air is better.
It's wedge shaped.
AUDIENCE: I think the
connotations of design
is purposeful.
So if you use it for
an unintended use,
I don't think it's
considered a good thing.
PROFESSOR: If I use it
for an unintended use,
it's not good design.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: Because when
a designer is designing
a product, they have a
specific use in mind.
And they're trying
to achieve that goal.
If they don't achieve that goal
and then achieve another goal--
PROFESSOR: What if they achieve
something far better, far more
noble, far more incredible?
AUDIENCE: That's not what
they were trying to do.
PROFESSOR: I know but
is it good anyway?
Does it matter what the
intent is is the question.
AUDIENCE: I think it
does matter what the--
PROFESSOR: You think
intent matters.
Who thinks intent matters?
Who thinks intent
does not matter?
Who's unsure about this?
Oh, yes.
This would be good for
a later conversation.
Let's consider this.
Good design-- now
know we're getting
really crazy-- is aesthetic.
What does it mean
to be aesthetic?
[AUDIENCE MEMBERS RESPONDING
SIMULTANEOUSLY]
PROFESSOR: Pleasing.
Pleasing in what way?
AUDIENCE: Visually.
PROFESSOR: Visually pleasing.
AUDIENCE: All ways.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: All ways,
PROFESSOR: Pleasing
in other ways too.
Not just visually but
auditorily pleasing.
Maybe the smell of a new car.
You don't think
they work on that?
Oh, they work on that.
In fact, Mercedes
once was having
an issue with some cars
because it didn't quite
have that Mercedes smell.
So they hired a nose.
Anyone knows what a nose is?
It's a person who
smells really well.
And it's about one
in-- I don't know--
100,000 people or 500,000
people or a million people who
have this great ability
to smell things well.
And the nose went to the car.
And they took this car.
They shipped it from wherever
the car person, owner was.
They gave her a different car.
They shipped it down.
And she [SNIFFING] smelled
all around the car.
Then she went, door,
take the door off.
And the went, OK.
They stripped the door off.
She's smelling around the door.
She said take this
panel off the door.
They took the
She's smelling and
goes, this is it.
This is the problem
right here, in the door.
It was the insulation.
And they went to the
insulation people.
They said, what did you
do to our insulation.
They said, we didn't do
anything to the insulation.
Show us what happened.
And they found out.
In one part of this process,
really early on, the insulation
had been stored in sacks
that had once stored tea.
Oh, yeah.
That new car smell,
very important.
So good design is aesthetic.
Who thinks this is true that
good design must be aesthetic?
AUDIENCE: It's something
that you're going to use
and you want it to be pleasing
in every sense of the word.
PROFESSOR: You want
it to be pleasing
in every sense of the word?
Who thinks it's not true?
Tell us why.
AUDIENCE: If you look at the
inside of a motor or something
that people aren't going
to look at I feel like what
it physically appears
like does not matter.
PROFESSOR: Great.
So you're saying if you look
at the inside of a motor people
where people aren't
going to look,
you think it doesn't matter?
There's a company that
disagrees with this philosophy.
And this company
is called Apple.
I bring up a lot
of Apple examples
because I happen to know them.
And I think it's
very interesting
because we are all
familiar with them.
Apple does something
interesting.
With the inside of an iPhone, if
you-- I'm not going to take it
apart-- I'll do a lot.
But if you take
the iPhone apart,
everything there matches
a certain color chart
that they have.
They have a color chart.
And if it doesn't
match the color chart
it doesn't go inside
there because they believe
if you start cheating
on the inside,
it'll begin to leak out.
And that cheating
will become revealed
on the outside of the design.
They think the parts that you
never see are still important.
When the Macintosh
first came out--
it was a big object like this.
A little small display.
And if you were
able to open it--
and it was only
meant to be opened
by professionals
who are in the shop.
You weren't meant to open
it because of the CRT
and it can be a very
high voltage there.
You open it and
take it off the back
and inside is a relief
of everyone's signature
who worked on that
product, inside that,
that no consumer
was meant to see.
Do you still think
it's unimportant?
AUDIENCE: I feel like what
makes a good design would
be other factors.
PROFESSOR: Other factors.
OK.
AUDIENCE: If you're talking
about like an engine
or something would you count
the sound of it as aesthetic?
PROFESSOR: I would count
the sound of an engine
as aesthetic.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So I want a car that
sounds like an angry weasel.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: You want your
car to sound a certain way.
People say, oh, the
roar of the car.
The roar of that V8
engine, they say.
Or that distinctive Porsche
sound they talk about.
Absolutely.
Think of the sound of the car.
Good design helps us to
understand a product.
Who thinks this is true?
Who thinks it's a lie?
Who thinks it's not necessary?
Good design helps to
understand a product, no?
We all agree on this.
What does it mean to
understand a product?
How do I understand a
paper cup or a bowl?
AUDIENCE: Well, there's
some cases in which you'll
have something and
people don't usually
read manuals or
anything like that.
So the more intuitive
you can make the design--
like make some
spot for, no, this
is clearly where your hand goes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Intuitive.
Something where
it's clear, where
you know how to interact
with it, engage with it.
Good design is unobtrusive.
What does it mean
to be unobtrusive?
What do you mean about good
design being unobtrusive?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
get in the way?
PROFESSOR: Doesn't
get in the way.
Who thinks this is true?
Who thinks this is not true?
Can you give me an example?
AUDIENCE: I think
there are buildings
that are very well designed
and they're very obtrusive.
PROFESSOR: Obtrusive
buildings that
are well designed but obtrusive.
What does it mean in that
context to be obtrusive?
AUDIENCE: They can obstruct
traffic, other buildings,
other--
PROFESSOR: They could
be obtrusive in terms
of the visual line.
Well some designs
are interesting.
This design is somewhat
obtrusive, particularly
when it's being used.
If anyone here has ever
been in an environment
where someone pulled
the fire alarm,
you'll know how obtrusive
a fire alarm can be.
But it's pretty good
because it needs
to be at that time
and not now, which
is why it's trying to be
a little bit more quiet.
It could be even better maybe
if we didn't see it at all.
Maybe.
I'm not sure.
There must be a reason why
they all have to be red.
I don't know what
that reason is.
AUDIENCE: I don't think
that premise applies
when part of your design is
to make something obtrusive.
PROFESSOR: When do you want
to make something obtrusive?
Give me an example.
AUDIENCE: When you
have a fire alarm.
PROFESSOR: Well
we're trying to make
it minimally obtrusive, right?
They could've made it this big.
It could be coming
out of the wall.
It could go off every
hour just to let
you know everything's cool.
What if they made
it half the size?
Or they could make
it even smaller.
Wouldn't that be better?
Maybe.
OK.
AUDIENCE: If you're Apple, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Good
design is honest.
Whoa.
What does it mean to be
honest in your design?
What does it mean to be honest?
Good design is honest.
AUDIENCE: If something
looks like it's
supposed to be doing a specific
thing it shouldn't do something
else.
PROFESSOR: So something looks
like it should do something,
it shouldn't be
doing something else.
So I shouldn't walk up
to this and say, oh, you
got a beautiful door stop.
I've been looking for
a door stop all day.
What else?
AUDIENCE: If it promises
to do something,
it should do that thing.
PROFESSOR: It should do the
thing it promises to do.
AUDIENCE: It should abide by
all regulations and safety
conditions so it doesn't
hurt you in the process.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It doesn't hurt you.
It protects the user.
AUDIENCE: Does that mean
you should design it
in an honest way, as in not
steal the design from somebody?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
Should you design it
in an honest ways,
as in not steal the design?
I don't know.
We should ask Samsung.
A little jab at that.
It's a good question.
AUDIENCE: I just don't know
what it's referring to.
PROFESSOR: I don't either.
I think we can actually find out
more information now about it.
But it's a good question.
What does it mean to be honest?
It might mean that as well.
It can mean a lot of things
about what its intended use is.
When I use it, does
it do what it's
supposed to do-- what
it promises to do?
AUDIENCE: It can
also be adding more
than it needs to be--
like making a gold hammer.
PROFESSOR: Gold hammer.
So that gold toothbrush
that we saw from Napoleon.
It may not be an honest design.
Maybe it's silver.
Silver toothbrush.
Can we think of an example
where this is not true?
Where design is dishonest?
Where you believe you
could do something with it,
but you can't and
it's still good?
AUDIENCE: For instance,
there's iPhone cases
that look like Game Boys.
PROFESSOR: iPhone
cases that look
like Game Boys that make
it not look like an iPhone.
Is that dishonest?
AUDIENCE: It might
be dishonest but I
think it's still good design.
PROFESSOR: What about up there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Little outlets.
You can't figure out how to get
this thing in til you turn it.
Dishonest design.
Who thinks that's
a dishonest design?
Who thinks it's an
honest design anyway?
Interesting.
What about this one.
What about childproof
bottle caps?
It looks like they
could be opened,
but if you are without the
skill, strength, or intellect,
then you won't be
able to open this.
Childproof bottle caps don't
just affect children though.
They can affect adults who
simply don't have the strength
to be able to open one of these
things-- to push down and open.
So they have other designs
to get around that as well.
But they're still a good design.
But is that a bit dishonest?
To give a whole population the
idea that it can be opened,
but you can't open it?
I'm not sure.
Good design is durable.
What does it mean to be durable?
What does it actually
mean to be durable?
For the design to be durable.
AUDIENCE: It's not
going to break.
It's last.
PROFESSOR: An object that will
last a decent amount of time.
AUDIENCE: I mean for the
design to be timeless.
PROFESSOR: For the
What do you mean by timeless?
AUDIENCE: It means that
five years from now it
won't look antiquated
and out of touch.
PROFESSOR: So years from
now, is it will still
look fresh and new and
novel contemporary.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The idea that this
was the intended concept and it
will still feel like
it's appropriate.
AUDIENCE: I feel like it's
sort of difficult to do
that though because--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Is it difficult?
AUDIENCE: --people's ideas of
what they want change a lot.
PROFESSOR: You say
that people's ideas
of what they want change a lot.
Tell us.
AUDIENCE: Well, maybe not
a lot, but if you look back
at older shows that were
predicting what the future was
going to be like, they might
be spot on with the technology,
but the aesthetics
of things-- we
tend to have more rounded
corners on things.
We don't like the
points as much anymore.
Things like that, that people
hadn't even considered back
then, are just taken for
granted now-- sort of.
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
mean, good design
can be determined
after the fact.
Maybe when you
make it, you don't
know if it's a good design.
And then after
tastes change and you
are 10 years down the road--
PROFESSOR: You're able
to see if it's still
a good, sustainable,
relevant design later on.
Interesting.
Good design is consequent
to the last detail.
Who thinks it's true?
Who thinks it's false?
Who is unsure?
Who did not vote?
Let's try it again.
Given your options, good
design is-- Let's clarify
what it means.
My mistake here.
What does it mean to be
consequent to the last detail?
AUDIENCE: Everything you
put in the design has
the intended effect.
PROFESSOR: Everything
you put in the design has
the intended effect.
Everything.
If you were going to give
me a written report--
a big one-- give me some
aspects of that report
that you'd be concerned about.
AUDIENCE: Whether or not
the content [INAUDIBLE] .
PROFESSOR: Content.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Citations.
PROFESSOR: Citations.
What else?
AUDIENCE: It's understandable.
PROFESSOR: If it's
understandable.
Comprehension.
AUDIENCE: Format.
PROFESSOR: Format.
So the--
AUDIENCE: Structure.
PROFESSOR: The structure.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I was going
to say the format.
PROFESSOR: Format.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Font size.
PROFESSOR: The font size.
And therefore, what else?
AUDIENCE: The font.
PROFESSOR: The font.
Absolutely.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Is it too wordy?
PROFESSOR: Length of words.
AUDIENCE: The paper
it's on itself.
PROFESSOR: The paper
Absolutely.
What else then?
AUDIENCE: Does it fulfil
the task and requirements?
PROFESSOR: Does it fill
We talked about the paper.
I heard something else here.
AUDIENCE: Color of the ink.
PROFESSOR: Color the ink.
Absolutely.
Color of the ink.
AUDIENCE: When you present the
paper-- like if it's bound.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
If it's bound.
If it's stapled.
How it's bound.
All these things are details.
Do you think they all matter?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Who thinks
if you take a paper that
has brilliant
content and a paper
with the exact
same content-- two
of them with the same
content-- and one
is stapled in the corner and
one is bound beautifully--
do you think that they will
affect your grade at all?
Who thinks it will
not affect your grade?
affect your grade?
That's good.
Statistics show that it
will affect your grade.
Everyone who doesn't think that
it doesn't affect your grade,
you should make sure that
your papers are well bound--
because it looks to someone
else like you put more work
and effort into it
and that you believe
more sincerely in your product.
AUDIENCE: A lot of that depends
on what the value system is
that you're working on.
If you don't actually
have the money
or you don't want to spend
the money to bind that paper
and you think that it's good
enough on its own then maybe
the best design
isn't binding it.
You might have a professor
who doesn't care.
Given it's on average you
will score higher [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So yes.
You have a specific case
where it doesn't matter.
That's true.
AUDIENCE: I think you're talking
about high school teachers--
that probably doesn't apply--
but once you start going
into college and you're
looking at the true content
of the paper--
PROFESSOR: You think it
applies in high school
but not in college.
AUDIENCE: I think it
applies less in college
than it does in high school.
PROFESSOR: I will tell
you this is not true.
I will tell you from firsthand.
And when I get a paper--
and I know this to be true--
if anyone submits
their midterm report--
their individual project--
and it is stapled
in the upper left hand corner,
you will with 100% certainly
be dropping the class
soon afterwards.
I've seen it every
single semester.
Every semester, I'll get
at least one person--
and I'll say, please
do not do that--
and they will give it to
me anyway bound like that.
And I just suddenly
have to count to 10
before they drop the class.
AUDIENCE: But do you ask
them not to staple it?
PROFESSOR: I say,
please don't use
a staple in the upper
left hand corner.
And they do it anyway.
There's a high
correlation between this.
And teachers, when you get
that beautifully bound thing,
you think, wow, look
how cool this is.
If you could sit in
those rooms, you'll
think there is a difference.
And of course, they will
read the content as well.
It's not that it's going
to make up for bad content.
But it shows a lot more
strength and structure.
And their brain will start
focusing a little bit
differently when they
review that paper.
Consequently to the last detail.
Who thinks that good design is
consequent to the last detail?
Who thinks it is not?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean,
it's the same thing.
It's just like, you
have to consider
what the audience will do.
You need to knowledge the
value of that extra detail.
If they don't value
it, like if you're just
trying to feed a lot of people
and they're just incredibly
hungry-- if you are trying to
feed a starving population,
they're not going to
care that you seasoned
the food that you've
made exactly perfectly.
They're going to care once
they get something to eat
and they get more of it.
PROFESSOR: What if you
could season it perfectly?
Would that be better design?
AUDIENCE: Well,
that would be great,
but that's not the
world we live in.
We live in a world
with limitations
PROFESSOR: Yes.
We do live with limitations.
But the question I would
ask you to think about
is when are those
limitations real
and when do we impose them
on ourselves unnecessarily?
When do we think, well, we can't
do this, instead of thinking,
well, maybe we can't do this--
let's see if we can do it.
You'll find a tremendous
amount of innovation
happens when we resolve
the tension between what?
From last class.
AUDIENCE: From what we desire?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
From what we desire
and what we require.
If we can resolve
these tensions,
that is where we get innovation.
Absolutely.
Good design is concerned
with the environment.
What does it mean?
AUDIENCE: Good design
doesn't neglect anything.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Good design isn't just sitting
in its own little vacuum.
It works within a whole
system, a whole big context
of things, whether it's
a physical environment,
a social environment,
or, like the iPod player,
works with the
iTunes Music Store.
It connects to other things.
Lastly, good design is as
little design as possible.
What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: I think
to use other things,
like how Apple used
previous designs.
So maybe they didn't have
to redesign that much.
PROFESSOR: So she's
saying less design.
Not as much redesign.
What other interpretations
do we have?
AUDIENCE: Keep it simple.
PROFESSOR: To keep it simple.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Going back to
the example of Apple,
they try to limit the number
of buttons that you have.
PROFESSOR: Try and
limit our buttons.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And also
with the mouse.
Let's use the Magic
Mouse for example.
There is no button like
there are with other mice.
There aren't two buttons.
It's just one
click that you use.
And it's very intuitive to
how you're going to use it.
PROFESSOR: So a Magic Mouse
has no buttons on it at all
and you can still click anyway.
And it knows what you're doing.
They're just trying to
reduce that user experience.
But they had a lot
more complexity inside
to figure out how
to make that work.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I think the
design is as little design
as possible as in off
of previous designs,
like going back to Dieter Rams.
PROFESSOR: Dieter Rams' work.
Absolutely.
Where he's really trying
to get that functionalist--
let's think about the functions
first and really build things
around in the simplest most
streamlined, elegant way
possible.
I want to consider these steps.
Part of your homework will be to
consider if these are all true
and reflect on them and see
how they can be improved
and which ones are missing.
I bet you're going to be able to
think of ones that are missing.
Design challenge.
Are you ready?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: I'll take that.
Here we go.
Are you ready?
This is what you know.
The music stops.
A man is dead.
That's all you know.
You need to solve what
happened and why did it happen.
And I will answer questions.
I will say, yes.
Or I will say, no.
Or I will say, Relevant.
That's what you get.
And we need to do this quickly.
Go.
AUDIENCE: Was the man
listening to the music?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Was he blindfolded?
If you happen to know
this particular question.
Was he blindfolded?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did he die
because the music stopped?
PROFESSOR: Did he die
No.
AUDIENCE: Is this a human
man who actually died and was
living and then now
is no longer living?
PROFESSOR: Was it a human
man who died who was living
and is no longer living.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did the music
give instructions?
PROFESSOR: Did the
music give instructions?
No.
AUDIENCE: Did he die while
the music was playing?
PROFESSOR: Did he die while
No.
AUDIENCE: Where'd this happen?
PROFESSOR: Where
did this happen?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1:
Yes or no questions.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 2:
Does the music stopping
coincide with the man's death?
PROFESSOR: The music stopped and
coincided with the man's death.
What's the question?
AUDIENCE: Did the music
coincide with the man's death?
PROFESSOR: I don't know
how to answer that one.
Give me some more detail
around the question.
AUDIENCE: Did they
happen at the same time?
PROFESSOR: No.
Did they happen
at the same time?
No.
AUDIENCE: Was he alone?
PROFESSOR: Was he alone?
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the
music stopping indicate
something else is starting?
PROFESSOR: Did the
music stopping indicate
something else is starting?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Was the music
playing in headphones?
PROFESSOR: Was the music
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the music
start in relation to
that the man was dead?
PROFESSOR: Did the music?
AUDIENCE: Did the music
start in relation to the fact
that the man was dead?
PROFESSOR: Did the music start
because the man was dead?
No.
The music stops.
The man is dead.
AUDIENCE: Did someone
stop the music?
PROFESSOR: Did someone
Irrelevant.
AUDIENCE: Did
someone kill the man?
PROFESSOR: Did
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the man have
a preexisting condition?
PROFESSOR: Do the man have
a preexisting condition
that was not covered
under the health code?
No.
He did not have a
preexisting condition.
AUDIENCE: Is the music
playing at a funeral?
PROFESSOR: Is the music
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the music stop
because it ended or did it
stop [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I can't
answer that question
with a yes, a no, or irrelevant.
AUDIENCE: Was the music short?
PROFESSOR: Was the
music to cut short?
No.
AUDIENCE: Was the man's
death an accident?
PROFESSOR: Was the
man's death an accident?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did the man die
before the music started?
PROFESSOR: Did the men die
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the man die
because the music stopped?
PROFESSOR: Did the man die
No.
AUDIENCE: Is the reason
the man died also
the reason that
the music stopped?
PROFESSOR: Is the reason
that the man died also
the reason that
the music stopped?
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the
man kill himself?
PROFESSOR: Did the
Ask the question differently.
AUDIENCE: Is the man
responsible for his own death?
PROFESSOR: Is the man
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Was the man involved
in stopping the music?
PROFESSOR: Was the man
involved in stopping the music?
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the man die
before the music stopped?
PROFESSOR: No.
He did not die before
the music stopped?
AUDIENCE: Was he in public?
PROFESSOR: Was he in public?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Was he driving?
PROFESSOR: Was a driving?
No.
AUDIENCE: Is the music
the name of something
unrelated to sound?
PROFESSOR: Is the music
the name of something
unrelated to sound?
I don't know what you mean.
But I want to.
AUDIENCE: Is the music a name?
PROFESSOR: Is the music a?
AUDIENCE: A name.
PROFESSOR: A name.
AUDIENCE: Of something.
PROFESSOR: Of something.
I don't know what that means.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1:
Is it not music?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 2: He
means is there a track
called "The Music."
PROFESSOR: Oh.
No.
Thank you.
It's hard.
It's not that hard.
AUDIENCE: Was the man
in control of the music?
PROFESSOR: Was the man
No.
AUDIENCE: Is the music relevant
to the man's death at all?
PROFESSOR: Is the music relevant
at all to the man's death?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did someone
try to stop his death?
PROFESSOR: Did someone
Irrelevant.
AUDIENCE: Did he want to die?
PROFESSOR: Did the
man want to die?
No.
AUDIENCE: Is the
song that was playing
relevant to the man's death?
PROFESSOR: Is the
song that was playing
relevant to the man's death?
-ish.
Sorry to break the format.
AUDIENCE: So is it an internal
injury that killed him?
An external injury
would be like a trauma,
whereas an internal injury
would be like a heart attack.
I'm trying to figure
out the way he died.
PROFESSOR: Ask me a
very specific question.
AUDIENCE: Was it
an internal injury?
[LAUGHTER]
Did he die of a heart attack?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: A stroke?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 2:
Something hit him?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: An ice
cream truck hit him.
PROFESSOR: No.
Did something hit him?
Yes.
Did an ice cream truck hit him?
No.
But that's very funny.
AUDIENCE: Was the thing that
hit him intended to hit him?
PROFESSOR: Was the thing that
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the music
player fall on the guy?
PROFESSOR: The music player
did not fall on the guy.
AUDIENCE: Since he
was blindfolded,
was he to guide himself
in a certain direction?
PROFESSOR: Ask the
question again.
AUDIENCE: Since he
was blindfolded,
was he using the music
as a way to guide himself
towards or away from something?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
She asked the question was
the music guiding him--
AUDIENCE: Was he using
the music to guide him--
PROFESSOR: Was he using
the music to guide him?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is the man a
performer of some sort?
PROFESSOR: Is the
man a performer?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Was he a
tightrope walker?
PROFESSOR: Was he
a tightrope walker?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did he fall?
PROFESSOR: Did he fall?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Was the
man using the music
to guide himself blindfolded
across the tightrope
and then the music
stopped and he fell off?
PROFESSOR: Was the man
using the music to guide him
across the tightrope--
AUDIENCE: While he
was blindfolded.
PROFESSOR: --while
he was blindfolded.
And what was the next part?
AUDIENCE: The music
stopped so he couldn't
find where he was going
so then he fell off.
PROFESSOR: The
music stopped so he
couldn't find
where he was going.
And therefore, he fall off.
No.
So close.
AUDIENCE: Was he supposed to
jump into a net and missed?
PROFESSOR: We he supposed to
No.
AUDIENCE: Did the
speakers fall on him?
PROFESSOR: Did the
No.
AUDIENCE: Was he
using the number
of beats to traverse
the tightrope?
PROFESSOR: Was using
the number of beats
to traverse the tightrope?
No.
AUDIENCE: Was the tightrope
the wire for the music player?
PROFESSOR: Was the tightrope
Very creative.
No.
AUDIENCE: Was the music supposed
to stop when he was at the end
but it stopped early?
PROFESSOR: Was
the music supposed
to be stopped when
he got to the end?
Yes.
And that's what happened.
So he's walking on a tightrope.
And all of a sudden--
he's blindfolded--
and the music stops, so he
figures he's at the end.
And he just steps off.
But he wasn't at the end.
And there was no net.
And he fell to his death
where the ground hit him.
[AUDIENCE DISGRUNTLEMENT]
You said, did something hit him.
Yes.
Something hit him.
I didn't lie.
Something did hit him.
AUDIENCE: He hit the ground.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
I'm sorry.
You've all taken physics.
The ground hit him as
much as he hit the ground.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: He wasn't dead.
He was still alive.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: The music
stopped before he died.
AUDIENCE: Because arguably, he
died when he hit the concrete.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
No.
I answered the questions
very specifically each time.
In fact, we have all
the questions, here,
that you asked.
Any ones in particular
that were of note?
So what's very interesting
here is about asking questions.
And it leads us
into what we want
to talk about here
with research.
Asking good questions
is really hard.
And when you ask
questions, sometimes you
find you're going down a path
that's giving you information.
Sometimes you don't.
Often the first question I
get asked was, was he outside?
No.
Was he in a building.
Yes.
What comes to your
mind as someone
said he was in a building?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: You'd think
an office building.
Right?
You wouldn't think
a tent or a circus.
That's a building.
It's a structure.
If I said no to building, would
I have to say yes to tent?
Like at some point if
I'm being very binary.
So asking questions
is very hard.
You see any ones
that you're skimming?
QUESTION TYPER: The internal
injury one was really good.
PROFESSOR: Internal injuries.
QUESTION TYPER: That put
them in the right direction.
PROFESSOR: Hitting the ground.
So when you said, did
something hit him-- well,
yes, something hit him.
But it doesn't tell you
about the direction.
Right?
And now you're
beginning to think
an ice cream truck struck him.
And this makes sense.
What you did is exactly right.
All this is exactly what you
should be thinking about.
But it shows us, given some
data-- think about when you're
asking questions-- you can
get the exact, truthful, right
answer and still be radically
incorrect about what
you understand from this.
That was a little
induction to research
here, complete with formula.
So research.
Just a basic thing.
You want to ask questions
and find out about stuff.
Asking questions is important,
but answers can be misleading.
Academic and scientific
research is often wrong.
We think it's the
truth when we read it.
And maybe it's truthful.
Many of them are very good.
But often they're wrong.
And we base beliefs and make
conclusions and decisions
based on faulty information.
Which gets us back
to the first thing
I talked to you about on
the first day, which was?
To do what?
The first thing.
AUDIENCE: Ask the
right question.
PROFESSOR: To ask why.
To make sure that we're getting
to the underlying reasons.
Because that may be wrong.
Research results may be good but
the conclusions may be wrong.
So here we had great research.
The question was, did he
die of internal injuries.
Yes.
Did something hit him?
What did we conclude?
That something hit him--
that he was stationary.
Easy to do.
This is Fitts' Law.
It's pretty cool.
I won't bother
explaining it right now.
It's so interesting.
It's used a lot in computer
and human interaction.
I'll give you the basic idea.
This distance is D. And I
think, here in the formula,
this is W, which really
talks about-- actually,
that's Ws here and Ws here.
It's a margin of
error, technically.
But here it's a width.
And what he would do
is he'd say, look,
we can have people doing
something like tapping.
Here.
As fast as you can.
Now if I take those
lines and I change them.
I'm going to make
them like this.
So that's one.
I do this.
Faster.
What if I do this?
Pretty good.
And so I'm pretty
good with that.
But my speed changed.
And if I wanted to go faster,
my accuracy would go down.
So what can we
conclude from this?
Lots of things.
Somethings that are very
good and somethings that
are incorrect.
One conclusion.
If I work on a computer
system that just
has a keyboard and
no mice at all.
And it's now 1985, 1986.
Should I use a graphical
user interface or not?
Well the incorrect conclusion
might be it will slow you down.
Because every time you
move your hand over-- we
can calculate it out.
How long it's going to
take you for every action
that requires you
to use a mouse.
And so we don't want to
have people slowing down.
We're going to keep everything
using keyboard commands.
But it may not be true that
it's going to make you faster.
That's an incorrect conclusion--
maybe given that same system.
But maybe if you
redesign the system,
it will actually become
a system that you
can use faster because
you can use the mouse
to be able to do things
you couldn't do before.
And the correct
conclusion that we draw
is the right click
for a pop-up menu--
you right click on something
and then the menu's right there.
So now you've moved
your hand to the mouse.
You move your mouse
to the target.
And you right click on it.
And now you have a
menu that's contextual,
that's short and easy to get to.
Instead of moving your
mouse all the way to the top
to a big menu bar and having to
find your way through cascading
menus.
That is the correct use of it.
Research results may be good
but conclusions may be wrong.
So when you see a really good
research piece like this,
understand that what you do
with that is really important.
We design projects for people.
People don't know
what they want often.
I could say, do you want
to have a device that's
this big and flat and has a
keyboard on it that's virtual
and all the stuff.
You might say, nah,
I don't want that.
In fact, when the iPad
came out, the week
beforehand or two weeks
before I had pre-ordered it
because I had to be
really cool and wanted it.
And my classmates were
saying, oh that's ridiculous.
I said, why is it ridiculous?
Well, it's like a bigger
iPhone and you don't need that.
And I'm like I think
it's different.
They said, no, it's
just a bigger iPhone.
We're not going to get one.
Well within a month, of
course, a whole bunch of them
are ordering them because
they saw it was different.
But if you asked them--
if you said, would you
like to pay $600 or $800
for an object like this,
they might have said, no.
And then they never
would've made an iPad.
It's very hard to ask
people what they want.
And if they know what they want,
they often can't articulate it.
They don't know what words
to use to convey the idea.
So as a designer
when you research,
how you ask questions, how
you interpret people's answers
is really critical.
I'd like to show you
this video about why
it can be hard to
get good answers when
you ask a question.
This video is for a game
show called the Family Feud.
Who does not know the show?
Briefly, here's how it works.
They have parts
of the show where
they ask people-- 100 people
get surveyed-- they'll ask them
a question like,
what would you expect
to find in a refrigerator?
And you want to guess
the most popular answer
because that will be the
number of points you get.
So what would you answer?
AUDIENCE: Milk.
PROFESSOR: Milk.
Milk is the most popular answer.
And so this is a speed
round at the end where
they have two different teams.
And this one person comes
over and he's looking away
from the board and this guy asks
him these questions in a row.
It's like five questions.
One of them is
the milk question.
You're asking this person
who's on a game show-- average
person, answering questions.
He happens to be under pressure
because he's on a game show.
You'll see his responses.
I'm just going to roll
this for a little bit
and then we're going to show
you the second part of this.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Name an animal
with three letters in its name.
CONTESTANT 1 (ON SCREEN): Frog.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Something
found in a refrigerator.
CONTESTANT 1 (ON SCREEN): Milk.
HOST (ON SCREEN): A
brand of gasoline.
CONTESTANT 1 (ON
SCREEN): Regular.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Something
that comes with a summer storm.
CONTESTANT 1 (ON SCREEN): Snow.
HOST (ON SCREEN): A sport
with an all-star game.
[BUZZER]
Turn around.
You may never be up here again.
Let's take a look.
Name an animal with three
letters in its name.
You said, frog.
Our survey said 0.
Two people would
have to say that.
Something found
in a refrigerator.
You said, milk.
Our survey said 28.
A brand of gasoline we wanted.
You said, regular.
That's a good brand.
Our survey said.
CONTESTANT 1 (ON SCREEN):
It's the brand I use.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Something
that comes with a summer storm.
You gave me the answer snow.
Our survey said.
PROFESSOR: So you saw
what happened here.
This person is trying to answer
questions under pressure.
He's trying to provide
the best answers he can.
An animal with three letters.
Frog.
I can see maybe-- it's
a short word, right?
Something in the refrigerator.
We got milk.
You all got milk.
You were great.
A brand of gasoline.
Regular.
He thought regular
is the brand instead
of Shell or Mobil
or something else.
That's what he associated
with that area.
Something that comes
with a summer storm.
Snow.
It doesn't happen
in the summer, I
think, for most
parts of the world.
Certainly not here.
But his reaction was to supply
an answer that wasn't useful,
even though he probably
would know things.
But under pressure,
not easy for him
to be able to come
up with good answers.
Let's continue this
and watch his opponent.
HOST (ON SCREEN): I got
good news and bad news.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON SCREEN):
Give me the bad news first.
HOST (ON SCREEN):
The bad news is
you need 172 points
to win the money.
The good news is you're
the man to do it.
I'm going to ask you
the same questions
I asked the other Bob.
You cannot and you do not
want to duplicate his answers.
If you do, you hear this.
[BUZZER]
What noise do we hear?
Thank you.
I will then say try again.
You'll give me another answer.
Alright?
Remind everyone, to
Bob's shame, the answers
he gave us and give me 20
seconds on the clock, please.
Name an animal with three
letters in its name.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON
SCREEN): Alligator.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Something
found in a refrigerator.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON SCREEN): Milk.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Try again.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON SCREEN): Ice.
HOST (ON SCREEN): A
brand of gasoline.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON SCREEN): Ethyl.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Something
that comes with a summer storm.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON SCREEN): Rain.
HOST (ON SCREEN): A sport
with an all-star game.
[BUZZER]
CONTESTANT 2 (ON
SCREEN): Football.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Football.
You've got to give him that.
Any man that says alligator,
you've got to give it.
Name an animal with three
letters in its name.
You said, alligator.
Our survey said.
You don't use narcotics.
Do you?
CONTESTANT 2 (ON
SCREEN): No, but I will.
HOST (ON SCREEN): I mean,
I thought frog was bad.
I thought frog was
a disastrous answer
until you came up
with alligator.
It's a real tough one.
Dog was the number one answer.
Dog.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON SCREEN):
Are you sure it was?
HOST (ON SCREEN): Three
letters in it's name.
Dog.
D-O-G.
[CHATTERING]
HOST (ON SCREEN): And
we wanted something
found in a refrigerator.
You both had this
nailed down very well.
Unfortunately, you repeated
his answer, which was milk.
But you said, ice.
That's the place to find it.
Our survey said 17.
Milk was the number one answer.
It was the only good
thing that Bob did.
A brand of gasoline we asked.
You said, ethyl.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON
SCREEN): A brand.
HOST (ON SCREEN): A brand which
I think you've been drinking.
Our survey said.
The number one answer was Shell.
CONTESTANT 2 (ON SCREEN): Shell.
HOST (ON SCREEN): Something
that comes with a summer storm.
At least you have reached.
Did you see his answer?
Snow!
At least you said,
I believe, rain.
Is that correct?
Well, that's good.
Our survey said 9.
And then a sport with
an all-star game.
You said, Football.
It was about two minutes late
but I insisted you get it.
Our survey said.
[BUZZER]
So these people are not stupid.
They're smart people.
They're regular people.
And they come with these
answers under pressure
which were just not the
right answers by a long shot.
So how you ask questions,
who you ask questions to,
the environment
you ask questions--
it may not always
be this extreme
where someone says alligator
for a three letter animal.
But you will get shades
of differences-- shades
of meaning.
Sometime who is
very stressed will
provide really bad answers.
If you're really, really--
I get test anxiety.
So when I took my
tests in grad school
I went to support services
and got time and a half
because I couldn't do it.
I'd be there and I would
look at these problems
and the information would
empty out of my mind.
I just was too anxious to do it.
Like other people, you will
get different responses.
So how you conduct your
research is really important.
So one of the various
ways we can research.
Let's talk about this.
If it was 1960, and
we wanted to learn
to cook like a French
chef, what would we do?
What could we do?
AUDIENCE: Go to France.
PROFESSOR: Go to France?
Just go to France?
And you just happened
to have the knowledge
by going to France.
Yeah. if you start
smoking, you get--
[GRUMBLES]
You walk down the street, and
you just happened to know.
No.
What else do you do?
AUDIENCE: Talk to
the chefs there.
PROFESSOR: Talks
to the Chefs there.
Sure.
What else could you do?
AUDIENCE: What about
French cooking school?
PROFESSOR: Go to
French cooking school.
AUDIENCE: Watch Julia Child.
PROFESSOR: Watch Julia Child.
Absolutely.
Watch her show called
The French Chef.
Yes.
This is good.
1848.
The best way to conduct a
defensive military retaliation.
AUDIENCE: Go to military school.
PROFESSOR: Military school.
Yes.
Look at the what's
happened before in history.
1990s.
The best way to clean a kitchen.
We want to make the best way to
clean the kitchens in the '90s.
What do we do?
AUDIENCE: Ask your mom.
PROFESSOR: Ask your mom.
If not, just ask your
mom, however, you
could also do what?
AUDIENCE: Watch her.
PROFESSOR: Watch her.
Yes.
2013.
You want to save money
on a call center.
This call center
handles technical issues
for customer complaints
for satellite television.
What can you do?
AUDIENCE: Internet.
PROFESSOR: What would
you do with the internet?
AUDIENCE: Just search for it.
PROFESSOR: Search for what
has been done to save money
in call centers that
have these issues?
I don't think
you're going to get
a whole lot of good responses.
AUDIENCE: Outsource.
PROFESSOR: Outsource what?
AUDIENCE: The people answering--
PROFESSOR: How would
you learn though?
How would you research this?
Have a consulting economy.
What would they do?
AUDIENCE: They would
go out and probably
talk to other people who have
done similar things in order
to--?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
They could talk to other people
who had similar problems,
but what about this
one particular call
center for satellite
TV, located in Denver?
AUDIENCE: Look at its budget.
PROFESSOR: Look it's budget.
What would you learn
from the budget?
AUDIENCE: Seeing where
the most money is going?
PROFESSOR: Well, we
know that a lot of money
is going to this thing.
How do we have them save money
on this one particular part
of the call center?
AUDIENCE: Reduce the
number of workers
by having an automatic system.
PROFESSOR: Reduce
the number of workers
by having an automatic
system, but how would you
know what the automatic
system should be doing?
AUDIENCE: Look at
what the workers do.
PROFESSOR: Look at
By what method?
AUDIENCE: Watch them.
PROFESSOR: Watch them.
Absolutely.
Actually sit down there
and watch the workers.
2015.
The decision to develop an
extremely new type of consumer
product, like when people had
to develop the iPad before they
developed the iPad.
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: Talk to people.
PROFESSOR: Talk to people
and ask them what they want?
What would you ask them?
What would you ask
people to figure out
that brand new product that's
different than anything
ever before it.
AUDIENCE: You talk
about what they actually
want like why they use iPads.
Maybe they want something easy
in front of them to touch.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So to get the
underlying mechanisms.
Yes.
So we have expert education
here, as he said, correctly.
Historical and cultural
explanations, as you
said correctly.
Ethnographic
research, as she said
about observing someone
actually performing these tasks.
This is how the
Swiffer was developed.
They had people with cameras
watching people clean and mop
their floors.
And they thought, oh wait,
they do all these things.
The water gets dirty
and all this stuff.
And they could
develop these ideas--
the wet Swiffer and
the dry Swiffer.
Here, direct observation.
Sit there and listen
to those calls coming
into the call
center, which I did.
And I heard them say things.
I sat down next to this person.
You know when they say
the calls may be monitored
for quality control
or quality assurance?
Well, that was me
sitting next to her,
jacked into the same box.
And I said, I'm just
going to hear what you do.
First call comes in.
I've got a problem
with my TV thing.
I can't get this
station and she'd
have a very interesting thing.
Did you diagnose it?
She'd work with them.
20 minutes later, it'd be done.
The next call would come in.
I've got this black screen.
She's like, oh,
we'll, can you go in
and unplug it and
plug it back in.
Sure.
Hey, it's working now.
Great.
Next call comes in.
I've got this really
strange problem.
I was getting these channels but
now I'm not getting anything.
She'd diagnose it and
send it a restart signal.
It would work.
The next call would come in.
I've got this snowy screen.
She'd say, can you unplug it.
Yes.
And plug it back in.
How's it working?
Works great.
Perfect.
Every other call.
Black screen.
Snowy screen.
Unplug it.
Plug it back in.
Resolved.
What's going on here.
I said, how do you know
that's the problem.
Oh, because the installers
say don't turn off the box.
They'd say you
don't have to worry
about turning off the box.
Turns out if you don't turn
off the box every week or two,
eventually it will
want an update,
not get it, and produce
a black or snowy screen.
And so she knew to do that.
They were given
incorrect instructions
by the people who
installed the box.
And she gave them
better instructions.
Well, kind of better.
The better instructions
we're actually, by the way,
you'll have to do
this periodically,
even if the installer told
you you didn't have to do.
So here by observing
that, we figured out
that 30% of the calls to this
particular part of the call
center were for a
black or snowy screen.
Automation was introduced,
as you said-- who was it?
Yes.
Correctly.
Automation was introduced
to solve this problem.
The first question was, are you
experiencing a black or snowy
screen.
No.
All right.
Let me give-- Yes.
Great.
Unplug it and plug it back in
and let's see if that helps.
I'll stay on the line.
When you're ready,
just say I'm ready.
And people would do that.
They'd say I'm ready.
Great.
Did that solve the problem?
Yes.
Alright.
You need to turn this
off, periodically,
like once a week or two.
otherwise you'll get
the same problem,
even if the installer told
you you didn't have to.
So that's how you
solve a problem.
Observation.
This is the hard one.
And this is exactly
what you're alluding to.
A deep understanding of humans.
What they want.
What their real desires
are-- technology, culture,
manufacturing, philosophy, art,
design, and everything else.
When you want something
really radically innovative
you need to understand
a lot about a lot.
And while you're in school,
you have an opportunity
to learn a lot about the a lot.
So take advantage of doing that.
Steve Jobs sat in on
a calligraphy class.
And that's why the first
Macintoshes had fonts.
Before, there were no
fonts in computers.
But he didn't have
this experience
of what a font can do and
change meaning of something
and he wanted that in that
first Macintosh computer because
of the experiences of sitting
in on a calligraphy class.
Have more experiences.
Understand everything about
culture, technology, art,
design, philosophy.
It'll make you
better at designing
very technical systems.
Any questions about that?
AUDIENCE: I would actually
disagree with that last point.
You get more innovation
by just trying 100 ideas
and seeing what sticks.
PROFESSOR: You think you
can get more innovation
by trying 100 ideas
and seeing what sticks?
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE]
that make great things
and have no idea
what they're doing.
PROFESSOR: You think
people who make
great things have no
idea what they're doing?
AUDIENCE: In some cases, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Can you
give me some examples?
AUDIENCE: Some examples.
If you think of a
product like Facebook.
PROFESSOR: Facebook.
He had no idea
what he was doing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, he was
doing something cool.
Ended up making a lot of
money later on by [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Making money.
But that wasn't the objective.
The objective was to
make something cool.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But he didn't
try 100 different designs.
Did he?
He didn't just try a 100
designs and see what stuck.
AUDIENCE: They updated
code twice a day.
PROFESSOR: That's not trying
100 different designs.
Facebook has maintained--
its core origin,
at the very beginning,
was a rating.
Hot or not.
Right?
So like, hot or not.
You would just rate people.
Then you started being
able to post more.
And it involved.
And when it evolved to
a certain point, then
it became particularly big.
But it wasn't that
they tried 100 designs.
No one sat there and said, let's
observe 100 different things we
could be doing for Facebook
and say, let's see what sticks.
People don't often do that.
It's also very
costly and expensive
to try 100 different designs.
AUDIENCE: If you look at how
they do agent testing everyday?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But that's making
small decisions.
But not radically
different things.
We're talking about technology
that's never been seen before.
A completely new type
of user experience.
Something that's never
been tried before.
Derivative things, absolutely.
You can do ABN testing.
You can test 100,000
variations in an hour
and see which ones
people used and which
ones they took longer to use.
But that's for small changes.
Not when you're doing something
completely radical and new
and very different
and very innovative.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to
support his point a little bit.
I don't think that
anyone who designs
these really good products
sits down one day and realizes,
given everything I know about
art, technology, society, etc,
this is how it should be.
PROFESSOR: You don't think so?
AUDIENCE: No, I don't.
PROFESSOR: If you were
to design something,
you wouldn't think that it
was the amalgam of everything
you've learned in
your life so far?
AUDIENCE: No, no.
It wouldn't just come at once.
PROFESSOR: It may
not come at once.
AUDIENCE: Unlike
the other examples--
in the other examples, you
narrowed down the [INAUDIBLE]
because you realized
this causes this.
PROFESSOR: Oh, right.
It is not a good example.
Exactly.
That is true.
But it is the
synthesis of everything
you've learned so far.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
But the process of getting
to the design that you get to
is a meandering.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
You may take a long time
to get to that design.
Absolutely.
Yes.
But it is the idea
that, if you-- I'll
bring this slide up again.
If you don't have a deep
understanding of people,
you're not going to design
things really well for them.
If you don't understand
how the technology works,
you won't be able to make
something that's useful,
that people enjoy
interacting with that
takes advantage
of the technology.
If you don't understand
about the culture
it may be the wrong
time to introduce it
to a certain place.
If the iPad was launched in a
poor country where they could
never afford it, then it
may not be very popular.
Or a place where there
wasn't internet reception
for some reason.
Or if you don't understand about
how to manufacture something
like that, then it
gets very clunky.
If you don't understand
about art or design,
how do you make something
that's aesthetically pleasing
and sustainable?
So that's why the
idea is to synthesize.
And yes.
It takes a long
time to get there.
That's why creativity gets
better as you get older.
The older you get, the
more creative you will get.
You don't get worse
with creativity.
It gets better.
Because you know more
and you have more life
experiences that
you can synthesize.
Other questions?
Or comments?
AUDIENCE: I feel
like it goes back
to the conversation we
had about intention.
PROFESSOR: Intention.
The idea of intention.
AUDIENCE: -and what
you intended it to do.
I feel like it does require
the deep understanding
of certain things depending
on what your design is.
But it's like what
you said, it can
evolve into different
things and that
might mean you will look for
more understanding of humans
and manufacturing maybe later on
depending on where the design--
PROFESSOR: So you'll
keep evolving that.
Absolutely.
You will definitely keep
evolving your ideas.
Joel.
PROFESSOR JOEL SCHINDALL:
Just to add a little bit,
I hope you're not falling
into the school idea
that these questions have
right and wrong answers.
These are thought provoking.
They're to get you
thinking about things.
They're to challenge
your assumptions.
Some of them are
absolutely ridiculous.
But without looking at
that, it doesn't give you
the perspective that
you're getting at.
I think you've probably done
this in other sorts of classes
but it's a different
type of perspective.
And to get the most
value out of it
you need to set aside--
by the way, the people who
are answering, I also want
to really hand it to you.
Put yourself out there.
Throw it out even if it's--
there are not right and wrong
answers.
We need illustrations
of the wrong answers--
we need illustrations
of the wide range
that people come up
with answers about.
I think if you're sitting
here in this class,
the answers that other
people are giving
are a demonstration of the
wide range of reactions
that people have to the same
stimuli that you receive.
And you'll receive a stimulus
and you'll say, oh, yeah,
of course that's true.
And someone else is going
to say, I object violently.
Now that's worth knowing
because that person's
giving an honest reaction.
PROFESSOR: The
whole point of this
is to provoke your thinking.
To make you think
deeper about this
and to set the
stage for what you
will be doing over the
course of the semester.
It is meant to
challenge the ideas.
We ask a lot of questions
about Dieter Rams' principles
and you'll be
reflecting on that.
But these are ideas.
And they're not meant to say
this is an equation where
when you put something in you
get something out like this.
It's not deterministic that way.
Design is a very, very
complicated thing.
That's why we talk about it
for many different aspects
and different approaches to
get you to think differently.
Because you'll be able to
soon become much better at it
through that process.
AUDIENCE: So I know that 2.009
is a very artificial setting
because you're given
a theme and you
have to design a product
based on that theme.
But how do you think 2.009
and that process fits with--
PROFESSOR: I don't know
a whole lot about 2.009.
You said it's an
artificial setting.
It's not that artificial.
There are companies that have
innovation labs where they say,
we do something with our
product in this space.
Can you do something
with our product
that takes advantage
of it somehow?
And people have to figure
out, OK, what do I have.
What are the resources?
How much time do
I have to do this?
Do I have an infinite
amount of time
or a limited amount of time?
And they do that same process,
just like you do in 2.009.
PROFESSOR JOEL SCHINDALL: Blade,
let me comment on that also.
Design takes place
at many, many levels.
And sometimes, you just
have a group of flowers
and you're trying to
make a floral design
and you're very restricted
in what you can do,
but there is a methodology,
there are rules.
You can put the big
flowers-- I don't
know how to do a good
one, so I better not
give you examples of that.
And on the other
hand, sometimes you're
trying to do either a very
complex technical system
or perhaps a complicated
political process.
People design press briefings
for presidential candidates.
It seems amazing.
It seems they're
so bad it doesn't
seem as if it could be designed.
But it actually
is very carefully
researched and designed.
Now 2.009 places itself
kind of in the middle
of the design space.
It's more creative
than just figuring out
how to assemble an erector set.
And it does encourage you to
do some innovative thinking,
but not as much-- we're trying
to go even one level higher
and something that will
apply to everything you do
and just, what we
call, design thinking.
And it will help you
in 2.009, but it's not
as specifically
applied to-- 2.009
is a mechanical engineering
course for people
who intend to grow up and
design mechanical things.
And so it focuses on that.
This is more for people who
intend to deal with life issues
and come up with answers.
PROFESSOR: Whenever you have
to do anything-- in my software
company, I apply
these principles
to everything we do-- the
ones I'm teaching you--
to every aspect of it,
whether it's to hiring,
to bring people on board, to
figure out what they're going
to be doing the next week,
how we're going to communicate
internally, how we're going
to communicate externally,
which brings us to stakeholders.
Cul Bono.
What does it mean?
Anyone know?
Who benefits?
So stakeholder.
Well the definition I get
off the internet-- a person
or group that has an investment
share interest in something.
We talk about stakeholders
for your education--
you or your family,
teachers, school.
Who else could be a
stakeholder for your education?
AUDIENCE: The community.
PROFESSOR: The community.
What community?
AUDIENCE: The one that you
would benefit if you go--
PROFESSOR: The
community that benefits
when you go and do something.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Your employers.
PROFESSOR: The employers.
Yes.
And actually
potential employers.
Who else?
AUDIENCE: The clients.
PROFESSOR: Clients.
When you're working at the
employer you have a client.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think the government
or the president in general.
PROFESSOR: The government
or the president, or you
could say the country.
The country benefits.
Absolutely.
Who else?
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if school includes
this, but your classmates.
PROFESSOR: Classmates.
Sure.
Tell me how your
classmates benefit.
AUDIENCE: The more you
bring to the table,
the more they're going to gain.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So when you have a certain
cohort in a business school,
if there's people with
different experiences,
they can bring new
ideas and formats.
That's why we have
discussions like this
at the beginning
of the lectures.
You get more benefit because
you hear someone's idea
that you hadn't thought
about before because they
bring their perspective.
Here's a quick sketch.
Just a quick sketch
of how you might
go about the process of
writing out the stakeholders.
Flour Bakery.
Who knows it?
A lot of you.
So this is a great
bakery, very close by.
And its owner is Joanne
Chang, a friend of mine.
And Joanne owns a bakery.
So I'm going to say that
this is in the center
and this is one of the
primary stakeholders.
Workers would be another primary
stakeholder of the bakery
because if the bakery's
selling product they get paid.
There's a whole bunch of others,
of course, that we can fill in.
Now we go from a secondary
one to the workers' banks.
How do they benefit?
Well, the Flour Bakery
gives the workers money.
The money goes into the banks.
So as we go through
that process,
the bank begins to be able
to get more money into them,
particularly a local bank,
perhaps, that's being used.
And what's
interesting about this
is there's a big
profound effect.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to have you do a quick
sketch for Flour Bakery.
And what I want you to
do is to do that system
with much more detail,
right now in class.
And if you need to,
you can use lines
to clarify what's happening.
Someone pays someone,
like pay the workers,
or the bank receives
cash as a result.
I want you to work
in groups of three.
If you have paper, please
draw this on paper.
And then, we'll project
a few on the screen.
So tidiness doesn't really count
as long as you can explain it.
And you'll have about
10 minutes to do it.
You can work with
any people you want.
By now, the students
are trying to figure out
how to map out a simple
stakeholder diagram.
Now this is not a very full
or robust stakeholder diagram.
It's just meant to
get everyone thinking
about the system
that's involved.
In a stakeholder analysis
that's done really well,
you'd actually phase out
all the different levels.
You'd think about all the
different stakeholders
and where they lie in the
spectrum of value, too.
Here we just want to make
sure that students understand
the idea that
things are connected
and that these connections
can seem very distant.
But if they understand the
connections and the space,
it can help them make
better decisions later on.
And we'll be doing that in
the next slides that we show.
We'll show what the students
have done on the screen.
So the thing to
look for in this is
to see if the students
pick up on some
of the other more
subtle aspects.
Are they going to think about
things like legal system
or the accountant
or people like that
who are direct benefits
and every store
has to work with their legal
people and their accountants,
but it doesn't seem like
it often pops in the radar.
And this is where all
these hidden costs
occur when someone's
starting a business.
They think, well, this one's
going to cost this much
or they're making a product
that's only this expensive,
but there's everything
else around that ecosystem.
And let's see if
they pick up on this.
All right so let's
go over your results.
Why don't we take
yours to start?
Does that sound good?
STUDENT PRESENTER
1: Sounds good.
PROFESSOR: You can
take care of this.
Let me know when you're ready.
So you're going to
have to explain this
because it's hard to get
the catch of this on here.
But it's OK.
Just walk us through it.
In fact, use the
laser pointer-- this
is the red button here at
the top-- to point out.
Tell us what we have over here.
STUDENT PRESENTER 1:
So immediately, you
have the owner who benefits
up here and also the employer.
And so from there,
their banks benefit.
And that kind of leads
into the economy.
PROFESSOR: Tell us about
just the first level, right
around here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT PRESENTER 1:
And so the suppliers
who supply the materials to
Flour, furniture, ingredients,
and stuff like--
they benefit as well.
And then down here, you
have neighboring stores
who benefit from the
popularity of Flour,
bringing in more traffic.
PROFESSOR: Neighboring stores.
Really creative.
They'll benefit from the fact
that it's a popular place.
Keep going.
STUDENT PRESENTER 1:
And so competition here,
you can extrapolate,
to them being
driven to produce better goods.
PROFESSOR: Wow, so competition.
That's very creative.
Keep going.
STUDENT PRESENTER
1: And this actually
feeds back in to customers who
benefit from better quality.
PROFESSOR: I guess competition
is a good drive out quality
from other bakeries who
aren't starting to get good.
Flour has to get better or
lower their prices or something.
Keep going.
STUDENT PRESENTER 1: Right.
And so the second level
here, back to the banks--
they benefit from
both the owners
and the employers making income.
And then down here, you have
friends slash the community.
Say you refer a
friend and they really
like Flour, that's
a benefit for them.
PROFESSOR: So it's a
benefit for the customer
if I refer a friend.
It's a benefit to me if I
refer you to go to Flour.
STUDENT PRESENTER 1:
It's a benefit for me
if you refer me to
Flour and I like it.
PROFESSOR: So you
get the benefit.
But are you attached
to me or are you
attaching directly to Flour?
In other words, do you
benefit directly from Flour?
STUDENT PRESENTER
1: That's fair.
You could say that I
definitely benefit from Flour
as well if I like it.
PROFESSOR: So maybe
this kind of line
would be a dotted line--
provides information to,
and then directly from.
Sure.
Keep going.
STUDENT PRESENTER 1: And so
naturally, the nearby community
also branches off from
the neighboring stores.
One more thing we have
over here is the publishers
because apparently Flour sells
cookbooks and stuff like that.
PROFESSOR: Flour
sells cookbooks.
There's a publisher involved.
And they love it.
The more Flour bakeries that
are around or the more people
know about it the more
cookbooks they buy.
STUDENT PRESENTER 1: And so
this leads to the bookstores,
I think.
PROFESSOR: Book stores.
Absolutely.
STUDENT PRESENTER 1: And this
actually feeds all the way back
to the economy.
And from the economy--
PROFESSOR: The economy "boomph."
Giant.
The beneficiary.
That's great.
And what comes off the economy?
STUDENT PRESENTER 1: And so
this is where we got creative
and said that the
government, the president
benefits from the
economy being strong.
And then you can even pull
out the political parties
if you wanted to.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So political party, government.
This is great.
So Flour makes America strong.
Forget GM.
Forget Ford.
Flour does it.
I love that.
It's a great job.
[APPLAUSE]
Who's up next on
the chopping block?
Let's get this going here.
You get this.
I'll give you this to hold.
I'll give you this
to use as well.
Let's talk about this.
Walk us through it.
At the center is Flour.
What else we got?
STUDENT PRESENTER
2: So we have Flour.
And then it first goes to
the banks and investors.
PROFESSOR: Investors.
Yes.
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: So banks.
So people who have
money in the bank.
So it's really important that
the banks are doing well.
Similarly, people
who are friends
with the people
with money the banks
who needed to be spotted for
a meal at Flour also benefit.
So we also have the workers.
Their taxes go to the
government which helps America.
And then workers.
Their families also benefit
from the making income.
And then it goes to
the school system.
PROFESSOR: How's it go
to the school system.
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: Because
the children go to school.
And then, thus,
benefits citizens.
PROFESSOR: So money goes from
Flour Bakery to the workers.
The workers give money
to their families?
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: Yes.
PROFESSOR: And so how does
that benefit the school?
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: Because
then the children go to school
and get educated.
You need people to go to school.
PROFESSOR: How do the
families pay for that?
STUDENT PRESENTER 2:
Through their taxes.
PROFESSOR: Through taxes.
STUDENT PRESENTER 2:
And then the government.
PROFESSOR: Before it gets to
the school, where does it go?
To the IRS.
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: That too.
PROFESSOR: And
them to the school.
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: Yes.
PROFESSOR: To the IRS first
and then to the school.
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That is true though.
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: And it
goes back to the citizens
because then you have
an educated population.
PROFESSOR: So Flour Bakery
educates the population.
I love that.
We'll tell Joanne.
She's going to love this.
STUDENT PRESENTER 2: Then
kind of going on a more fun
note-- so we also had
neighboring companies,
such as Novartis who's like
a biotech drug development
company which helps hospitals.
And then the patients
can go to Flour.
PROFESSOR: Lovely.
Keep going.
STUDENT PRESENTER
2: Similarly, we
have more customers
such as MIT students.
And so our parents benefit
from us getting an education.
Professors and other MIT
employees who go to flour.
And also the world slash
everybody is invested in.
PROFESSOR: The world.
I can't wait til the next
one that says universe.
That's good.
Big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
We've got time for
one more example.
Who-- yes.
Let's take your example.
Cannot wait to see it.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: So ours is
similar to many of the others.
We have some things that
other people didn't have--
PROFESSOR: Point
out the differences.
STUDENT PRESENTER
3: --in local gyms.
PROFESSOR: Local gyms
benefit from Flour.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: They do.
PROFESSOR: Tell us why do local
gyms benefit from a place that
sells lots of bakery
confectioneries.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3:
Flour is really delicious.
And then people eat a lot of it.
And they get really fat.
And then they would like to
lose some of those calories.
PROFESSOR: So the Z
Center, the MIT gym,
benefits from Flour being there
because more people use the Z
Center who may not otherwise
use it because they're saying,
I love Flour so much but I've
got to work out the calories.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: Exactly.
PROFESSOR: Local bike
shops maybe as well.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: So
their employees benefit too.
PROFESSOR: Their employees
absolutely benefit.
Yes.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: And we also
had hospitals in that similar--
PROFESSOR: As Diabetes go up.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: Exactly.
PROFESSOR: Yes, they're so
tasty they cause diabetes.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: Precisely.
PROFESSOR: And
hospitals benefit.
And doctors from selling--
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: And
the doctors' families.
Yes?
PROFESSOR: And the
doctors' families benefit.
STUDENT PRESENTER 3: Exactly.
PROFESSOR: Now this may sound
bizarre, but this is true.
This is how it happens.
Imagine that we had to work
it out for a tobacco company.
All the people that benefit
from a tobacco company
selling things,
including people who
are injured by tobacco
because of cancer.
So that's all true.
What else do we have?
STUDENT PRESENTER 4:
We had aspiring chefs
because of the cookbook.
So they can see that.
Or even aspiring
restaurateurs who
see how the owner set
up Flour and maybe
use it as an example
or inspiration.
PROFESSOR: Brilliant.
What else do you have?
What else is brilliant?
STUDENT PRESENTER
5: We also have
how MIT is generally affected.
So if students are eating at
Flour instead of the dining
hall, then that's affecting MIT.
That's affecting the
classes and the professors
and your classmates.
PROFESSOR: And maybe for good.
Maybe not for food.
This is great.
This is an excellent one.
Here's a question.
Did anyone get lawyers?
Good.
Two groups.
How about accountants?
One group.
Excellent.
Every business deals with
lawyers and accountants.
Lawyers accountants
all the time.
Every business, no
matter what, deals
with lawyers and accountants.
It should be on all of
these because, no matter
what-- and particularly
as a business owner-- boy,
I get on the phone
with my lawyers,
I talk to my accountant.
I can't even avoid it.
It's not even possible
to avoid, particularly
when you have to hire people and
fire people and the whole bit.
That's why they're such
big businesses-- why
accounting and the law
are such big businesses--
because everybody
needs to use them.
Any other people have
examples of beneficiaries
who we didn't list?
AUDIENCE: Insurance companies.
PROFESSOR: Insurance companies.
Yes.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: The farmers.
PROFESSOR: Farmers.
People actually grow this stuff.
Absolutely.
People grow stuff and
have more supply chains.
And this is true.
Flour Bakery may
have a little impact,
but McDonald's has enormous
impact on cattle companies,
and people who supply
tomatoes and lettuce and all
those things.
Absolutely.
Huge impact.
Industries are built
around these things.
AUDIENCE: We also listed
internet providers
because they offer free
Wi-Fi to the customers.
PROFESSOR: Free Wi-Fi to
the customers as well.
Let's go back to slides, please.
Thank you.
This is excellent.
You did a great job.
Did we give them a
round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
You got that.
This is what we
care about though.
Why do we care about
doing this and why are you
going to be doing
this yourselves?
It's starts out with
systems thinking.
Establishing a
global perspective
about the little problem
you're trying to solve.
If I said, make a
calculator-- a calculator
doesn't exist in isolation.
It affects a lot of things and
can affect a lot of things.
We want to maintain a
really big perspective
over every small
decision we make.
Because of that,
we can understand
how to make good
decisions and trade-offs,
establish priorities or
reestablish them, and be
able to communicate
more effectively.
Not all stakeholders have
the same amount of value
to a company.
Different stakeholders hold
different kinds of value.
Joanne may say, look, I
really care about my customers
but she may not
say, I really care
about the people
who work at the gym.
So she may not say, let me
put extra fat in the products
and then advertise, by the
way, with these things,
if you care about
it, I'll give you
a discount to the
gym membership.
Which stakeholders
do we benefit more
and which stakeholders
benefit us more?
Sometimes, in a
nonprofit, we might
think we really want to get
the best thing out there
no matter what because we
don't care about making profit.
Other times you think, well, we
want to get the best thing out
there, kind of, but
we also want to make
sure we're balancing that
out with our stakeholders.
An example of this
is angel investors
versus venture capital.
If you're starting a
company, angel investors
will give you a
little bit of money.
It's a little bit
easier to get the money.
And there's far fewer strings
attached to that money.
A venture capitalist will give
you money-- much more money,
but they have a lot
more requirements.
And so each of them need
different kinds of things.
Angel investors don't need
a whole bunch of return
on their investment.
And a venture
capitalist says no, we
want to make a ton of cash.
So we'll give you
more, but we're
going to take a lot more back
and have more requirements.
So different kinds
of stakeholders
would allow us to figure
out which do we use.
If we understand this
network very clearly,
it helps us to understand
priorities and trade-offs.
And then, if I
understand this diagram
and convey this to
you very specifically,
it could help us align the team.
So my software is sold
to people at companies.
If everybody in my
company knows who
those people are, who makes
the buying decisions, who
is going to use it.
Are they the same people
or different people.
How do I make sure that
the buying person gets
what they need and the person
using it gets what they need.
They may need different things.
And even though the
people who use it
may use 90% of the
functionality and the people who
buy it may use almost
none of it, or 1%,
do I want to invest that
1% of the functionality
even if it costs me a
lot of time and effort?
Maybe I have to.
So it can reveal hidden
cost and opportunities.
A cost.
A student can get an
easy or a difficult C.
From a parent's perspective,
which is better?
The easy A or the
really difficult say?
Please pass the class.
I'm your parent paying for it.
I don't want to have to pay
for you to take it again.
So maybe they might
think it's really better
to have an easy A class.
But maybe from the
student's perspective,
they think, the
harder C is-- I'm
going to learn a lot more in.
And it's better for
me and my future.
Or an opportunity.
If a company has enough
employees, for example,
a company can get
better buying power
with vendors or the
gym or something.
Because we have
so many employees
they say, look, we want
to have our employees go
to your gym or maybe
some competitor's gym.
If you give a bigger discount,
we have more buying power.
Or to the vendors like Walmart.
Walmart doesn't pay
much for anything
because they sell so much.
And it's such a
valuable brand to have
when you're selling
something that they
make their vendors cut
their prices way down-- as
low as they can
possibly get them.
And the idea is that
for them is they
pass their savings
on to the customers.
For the homework, I
want you to map out
primary and secondary
stakeholders,
and more if you'd
like for two things.
An art museum and a new
kind of battery technology.
So one's a museum and
one is a technology.
Starting with technology
in the center.
I'm thinking about that.
All the different
ways it connects
to everything else around it.
A new kind of better technology.
If you have something in
mind, you could use that.
Just let us know what you used.
And if you don't really quite
know about battery technology,
you could just kind of think
about what it might affect.
That's the objective here.
Understanding your stakeholders
will make a huge shift
in your ability
to make decisions,
to think globally from
a systems perspective.
And if you can do that
on little small projects,
as the projects get bigger and
more complicated and complex,
you'll be able to
make better decisions.
And it will help
you make decisions
when you're not too sure what
to do because at least you'll
have a framework and be
able to communicate that
to other people on the team.
And they can say,
yes, we understand
that that's an important
feature to add--
to spend weeks or months
adding because someone needs it
in order for us to
sell the product.
Any questions about
stakeholders or research
or Dieter Rams or Johnny Ive?
AUDIENCE: Is the
homework for Monday?
PROFESSOR: This
homework is for Monday.
In fact, I will show
you on the next slide
what you've done so far.
We had an introduction.
We went over the 10
step design process.
We actually moved
Dieter Rams to today.
And what's due on Monday
is the game design
and the stakeholder
analysis for games.
Have a wonderful weekend.
If you have any questions,
email us at eid-questions.
Thank you.